l' alerte verte c'est celle que rené
dumont le premier candidat présidentiel
écologistes agité dès 1974
[Musique]
vous savez ce qui va se passer eh bien
nous allons bientôt manquer de l'eau et
c'est pourquoi je bois devant vous un
verre d'eau précieuse puisque avant la
fin du siècle si nous continuons un tel
débordement elle manquera à lundi je
vous dis au revoir et j'espère vous
revoir pour vous expliquer notre projet
global d'avenir merci mes amis de
alerte qui a mis du temps beaucoup de
temps à être prise au sérieux valérie
pécresse oui alors j'appartiens comme
vous savez à une filiation où on s'est
beaucoup préoccuper d'écologique ce soit
jacques chirac avec le discours de
johannesburg que ce soit nicolas sarkozy
avec le grenelle de l'environnement moi
cette préoccupation écologique
elle elle est très forte en moi comme
ministre de la recherche j'ai fait
tranché l'académie des sciences sur
l'existence dû réchauffement climatique
et sur la responsabilité de l'homme dans
ce réchauffement à l'époque vous savez
claude allègre aller sur les plateaux et
désespéré les climatologues en disant
que le réchauffement climatique
n'existait pas et le fonctionnement
médiatique étant ce qu'il est sur les
plateaux il y avait 1 pour 1 contre et
un journaliste au milieu qui ne
prenaient en général pas partie donc les
climatologues m'avait saisi en disant
fait rétabli c'est la vérité et donc
j'ai fait tranché l'académie des
sciences c'était une des dernières
académie qui s'était pas prononcée
encore sur le sujet alors cette urgence
climatique elle nous oblige est l'un des
grands enjeux du prochain mandat
c'est celui que qui est décrit dans
votre dans votre dans votre petit
extrait c'est celui de la gestion de
l'eau qui va devenir une question très
dramatique avec le réchauffement nous
avons besoin de respecter les
engagements de la conférence de paris
aujourd'hui la france ne respecte aucun
donc nous devons nous mettre dans une
trajectoire qui nous amènera au zéro
carbone 2050 nous devons nous mettre
dans une trajectoire qui préservera les
ressources de la planète mais ma
conviction c'est que l'écologie c'est
pas une idéologie l'écologie c'est des
résultats concrets c'est des résultats
en termes de baisse de pollution c'est
des résultats en termes d'énergies
propres et des résultats en termes de
sobriété de consommation s'est inventé
une nouvelle croissance qui sera sobre
parce que moi je ne crois pas à la
décroissance pas dans un pays avec des
difficultés sociales aussi forte que la
france nous avons besoin de ne pas
opposer l'écologie à l'économie mais
c'est toute l'économie qu'il faut
redéfinir
construire réinventer
[Musique]